-Now, you all know
how to play charades.
Each player gets a turn giving
silent clues to their teammate.
30 seconds on the clock
per turn.
We'll do four rounds.
Then the fifth round
is a charades showdown.
-Mm!
-Mm-hmm.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first. You guys
can all take your seats.
Jamie, you guys --
You and Taron over there.
Zoey over there.
-Over here.
-Yeah, perfect.
All right, here we go.
What number shall I choose?
-Four!
-That was weird.
Why did everyone say four?
Everyone all yelled four.
That was --
That's never happened.
The whole crowd
just yelling four.
Unless -- Wow. That was...
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
So you want to go with --
No, I'm just kidding.
All right. I'll go...
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm,
mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Okay. All right. Ready?
-Yes.
TV show.
-Uh-huh.
-Three words.
First word. The. It. The.
"The Rabbit."
[ Laughter ]
The -- The -- Zorro!
The --
Fangs! The -- the -- the --
Bite! No! Uh...
The -- Fangs!
What's the third?
The vampire!
"The Vampire Writer."
"The Vampire."
The book.
"The Vampire Slayer."
"The Vampire"...
[ Buzzer ]
What is it?!
[ Tuba plays sad notes ]
-"The Vampire Diaries."
I know.
"The Vampire Diaries."
I-I was trying to do a diary.
All right. All right.
-Did you get that?
Did you get that?
-Yeah. I was there
for quite...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I have failed miserably.
-What? What?
You want the...
[ Tuba plays sad notes ]
[ Laughter ]
You like that?
Unbelievable you like that.
All right. All right. You're up.
Jamie, you're up.
-I'm up.
-I am sorry.
-What number should I pick?
[ Audience shouting ]
What?
One.
One?
-Yeah.
Oh. Ohh.
Uh -- Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Ohh.
-So it's a film.
It's a little film.
[ Laughter ]
It's five words.
The first word is little.
Small? The! The.
"Lord of the Rings."
-Wow!
-"The Silence of the Lambs."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Wow! [ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
Rub it in.
-Just too humble.
-You just...
-You got to follow that.
Oh, my gosh.
"The Silence of the Lambs."
-Just so humble. Okay. Guys.
-I was -- Sorry.
[ Audience shouting ]
-You got chemistry.
I'm ready.
Zoey, we got this.
-Okay.
-Come on. We can do this.
Mm-hmm. Wait. What?
-We got this.
-Oh, okay. Good.
Yeah, I thought it was like --
First clue. I'm like,
"I don't know what that means!"
-We don't got this, apparently.
-No, we got this. Here we go.
It's a song. Yeah. Two words.
The first word. Crazy!
[ Laughter ]
"Crazy Train"!
♪♪♪♪
-AAAH!
[ Waltz plays ]
♪♪♪♪
I, too, can be humble.
-Yes.
Taron, are you up?
-Oh, I'm ready.
-Oh, yes.
-What number am I going with?
[ Audience shouting ]
Okay. Uh, okay.
-All right. Let's do it.
Okay. All right.
[ Laughs ]
Television. Four words.
First word.
Ba-- Dance. Ballet.
Uh, uh, slow music.
-[ Groans ]
-Uh, tights.
-Okay. Uh -- uh -- uh...
First word -- Four words.
Four words.
Two times --
Two plus two is four.
[ Laughter ]
Quattro! Okay.
-The fourth word.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Tuba plays sad notes ]
-Can I guess?
"Dancing with the Stars"?
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right. Here we go.
Jamie, You and Zoey
are going to give the same clue
at the same time, okay?
Whoever wins this round
wins the whole thing, okay?
Oh, pl-- Look at this.
Oh, my gosh.
Ohh! I can't do that.
-It's a walk-off.
-But I'm going to attempt.
There we go.
-It's a walk-off.
All right. Here we go.
What number? Shout it.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Every number.
-Now you both read it.
You both read the clue.
There you go.
-Oh, man. Hell no.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. You ready?
-Yeah, are we ready?
We can do this.
-Okay.
-Go. Okay, film.
-TV show.
-Spy. The spy.
-Shark. "Sharknado."
-The spy who --
-The pillow.
The book that --
You can't find it.
The search for...something.
The look -- The search --
I don't know --
-"Through the Looking Glass."
-Where are --
Where's my glasses?
Second word.
-"Finding Nemo"!
"Finding Nemo"!
♪♪♪♪
-You guys!
The winners right there!
Jamie Foxx. Taron Egerton.
Zoey Zeutch is my partner.